in Massachusetts we know a thing or two
about revolutionary ideas and at MIT we
know a thing or two about innovation and
entrepreneurship together the
universities communities and industries
of Greater Boston have transformed this
region into one of the hottest
innovation ecosystems on the planet a
place that's home to everything from the
most dynamic and for thinking companies
to the startups nipping at their heels
but we and other innovators in the area
got to thinking what if we could go
further what if we could cut the time it
takes for world-changing ideas to go
from Lab news to marketplace help
entrepreneurs find support to take on
the most difficult challenges accelerate
growth in the toughest technologies to
tackle the toughest problems
what could we build to make this a
reality we build an accelerator to help
ambitious startups get from concept to
company and from prototype to production
we provide financial support for
innovations that require long lead times
to develop and we establish a network
linking the ecosystems of Cambridge
Boston and beyond to share vital
equipment maker space and diverse talent
we'd rally our colleagues across the
region and together make more than
financial commitments we would make a
pledge to use our energies our brains
and our skills to push the boundaries of
the possible we would build a new kind
of accelerator what is tough as the
technologies it will drive as
revolutionary as the ideas it will
support to do all this we would build
and engine